if your ambition is your side hustle to
become your actual hustle the key is not
how much you work it's not even how much
time you put in the side hustle it's
every other hour because every other
hour needs to cut be put into the side
hustle which speeds up the side hustle
to become your actual hustle and that's
what a lot of people side hustles want
to happen
you got your perspective and I see these
dreamers would he say to them about
balancing a difference between dreaming
and execution I mean how do they how do
people work out because you're gonna
dream a hard a lot and then you're gonna
act then you've got to stop me gonna
start executing hard a lot then you've
got to get back to dream because your
life can't be just about executing it's
gonna be there dreaming that's right
yeah yeah if they're strategizing
execute that people saying you change
your moral time first of all I I think
changing your mind all the time is the
core strength of a human being it was an
ability I'm just racing what I'm doing
my dad used to gets so mad at me you you
just said a week ago that we were gonna
sell rose' I'm like am i changing my
mind
customers came in I didn't like the way
it felt I changed my mind I think
changing their mind is a huge strength I
and it's funny I was about to answer and
we brought up the change of mind I think
it's the same thing I think a lot of
people don't fire people don't change
their mind because they're greatly
insecure this is an enormous game of
insecurities you know why do people
dream and not do they're insecure they
inherently don't think they can do it
the system makes us be that way to learn
about America yeah hundra he a
regulatory environment yes it sort of
enhances this insecurity which puts you
the position we can't fire somebody yeah
[ __ ] that yeah I do you know some of my
guys you though
I was my I'm a lot more educated in the
UK version and I and I'm aware that the
Australian version is closer to that
that is some [ __ ] horseshit
yeah anything that eliminates merit is
bad yeah if somebody sucks and you can't
fire them you the whole thing's broken
yeah darlin the hell are we doing here
well my not battle with a little time we
get kills me um and like I ever did TV
show you've ever actually had to say
you're fired
and it's not very Australian to do that
because it's considered an uncool to
fire somebody but in my business like I
mean I'm sorry I just can't put up with
something that doesn't work more
importantly leads to entitlement and
entitlement is poison yeah
a hundred percent yes I do believe that
I do believe that there is a scenario
just like chief brand officer x' and
chief marketing officers our last 30 40
50 year phenomenon I'd be surprised if
in 15-20 years we don't wake up and most
of the major brands in the world have an
editor in chief I actually think a lot
of the concern of my journalist friends
I always remind them I'm like look
there's evolution maybe you're not gonna
work for the magazine you've worked for
but maybe you're gonna work for you know
your favorite brand and so yes I mean I
think great storytelling in the form of
an incredible writer is something that
never goes out of fashion regardless of
the platform that they write on and how
it changes
well you'll appreciate this you know
here here let me let me let me tell you
how I build credibility by not trying to
sell people something in it in my posts
you know like you know it's not it's not
hard for Nike to build the credibility
if they write an article about
cross-training without mentioning their
product it's not hard it's foreign it's
not how people are thinking today but
you know it's not difficult for a
coconut drink to talk about you know
health and wellness without mentioning
its strength they they can this is why I
want them to hire journalists you hire a
marketer she and he's gonna want to sell
you hire a journalist they're gonna not
want to sell out
[Music]
this is the primary message you get
across to people you've got to grind
24/7 you you know you got to do what you
got to do but my question is really
about with working that hard you know
every human being comes in to the point
where you've got to strike a balance or
people say I think you do i I think I
think early you know I kind of hit the
scene in 2009 and we were in a global
economy meltdown right and and we were
living off of a frothy 2000 to 2007 8
and I thought that people were under
estimating work ethic and so yes hustle
was something that I was articulating as
a foundation of my success but I only
think one should work a lot if they
genuinely enjoy it you know or they have
to provide for their family and they're
working two jobs and it's almost a
screaming the other way
I I'd like to do a better job over the
next decade to to make sure that my
primary message is happiness I mean that
that being said in the extreme
overcorrection
where people have started branding
things like hustle porn or things that
nature a hard work is part of the
equation but yes I think burnout or
mental anguish is something I'm very
scared of but I do not believe that
comes from I think a lot of people put
hard work as the Gateway to that issue I
actually think that that is insecurity
and lack of self-esteem that leads to
that anguish which so my follow-up
question with that comment is quite
simply you know there is quite an
interest and it's a very popular thing
it's the cool thing to do become an
entrepreneur right everyone wants to be
an entrepreneur hundred percent you know
when I was at this event where you spoke
there's about 5,000 people and I can say
everyone wants to be a yes do you think
there's a danger yes not everyone is cut
out yes okay so so how do you how do you
tell somebody that you know they've been
they've been hustling as hard as they
can but something's not working out how
does one figure right I'll give up I
asked them if they're happy right you
know like if you're hustling your
podcast and three sheer will through
live events and pre-roll advertisers and
you're making forty-two thousand a year
if that's more fun and you're happier
than making 78,000 being you know an
accountant then I try to encourage that
person to live the lifestyle of a 40 mm
your person versus a 78,000 your person
I I think that if I think we have to
define our own success and I think doing
what you want to be doing is the
ultimate right now there's the practical
application looks like you know yes but
that's a modern mistake in that people
usually spend more than they make
there's a lot of immigrants who take
care of their family making 35,000 a
year the problem is there's a lot of
people who make 200 thousand a year and
live like they're making 300 thousand
because they want to keep up with the
Joneses and they want stuff I mean you
can live a lot of ways you know family I
lived in a I once lived two years with
my great grandparents and my
grandparents and my parents in a home
you could do that especially 25 year
olds who are like complaining go live
with seven of your buddies in a [ __ ]
place like I'm fascinated by people's
misunderstanding of it's not how much
you make it's how much you spent yeah of
course if you take [ __ ] uber and
order out every night and need the
freshest [ __ ] fly as flexi excluse
you're gonna need a [ __ ]
money yeah why not take the train why
not live in a shitty spot why not cook
every night like people are [ __ ]
entitled
[Music]
what are the three most interesting
things about you that don't normally
come up in conversation and you have
probably the hardest guest to come up
with anything I'm remarkably
non-confrontational in real life even
though I'm a tough guy on video in stage
I sleep seven to eight hours a day no
yep
ma I mean six one and five when I travel
and I really don't I genuinely don't
care if I'm financially successful
[Music]
thank you think yeah well a lot about
users are just starting out their side
hustle is it yes yeah trying to you know
try to make an action my PB to the exit
works or like what's your advice again
patience yeah you know cuz a lot of
times when you're doing a side hustle
you can't wait for it to take over your
job that you hate patience and then
audit your other activities if your side
hustles ambition is to be your normal
life you have to scrutinize what you're
doing on Netflix you have to scrutinize
candy crush you have to scrutinize the
movies you have to scrutinize baseball
cards and footy and sneaker collecting
if your ambition is your side hustle to
become your actual hustle the key is not
how much you work it's not even how much
time you put in the side hustle it's
every other hour because every other
hour needs to cut be put into the side
hustle which speeds up the side hustle
to become your actual hustle and that's
what a lot of people side hustles want
to happen and I've noticed it going over
them to or not texted them and what's
your yes it works it works you know
having 70,000 people on a text messaging
platform like I do right now
converts better than having 3 million
followers on you know on Facebook is
that one-to-one conversation right
that's right and it's cool like I grew
up loving Randy the Macho Man Savage if
he had seen and the Macho Man texted me
back I'd lose my mind I'd be stoked so
that's why see and in terms of I mean
platforms these days I know you back in
Tito colores yes LinkedIn do you please
you know he's starting out again come
back in after their community in those
do they need to make content I think
both can work but the reason platforms
matter is first matters yeah best always
in the end but first does matter
so if you're the first lawyer in
Australia to get on tick-tock and
tick-tock becomes Instagram and goes
mainstream there will be dibbens there I
think I think one of my biggest
strategies around social media is to
start with yes while everybody else
starts with no no I'm not gonna be on
tick-tock that's for twelve-year-old
girls
I'm always yes yes yes yes yes yes and
by the way the famous yeses of Instagram
and Facebook and and and snapchat nobody
talks about the non famous yeses I was a
yes on peach I was a yes on Socialcam I
was a S on vero I put in a lot of time
and effort not necessarily to post but
to watch those platforms that people
thought were gonna be the next big thing
and they did it and but I don't you that
as wasted time a yes culture strategy
always works
[Music]